I mentioned at the top of the show you
know this time of year we're about to go
on our vacation and this is this is just
a great time of year in general and you
know summertime do whatever you want in
the summertime have a good time let your
inhibitions go and well I don't know
about that what we did we decided to
Andy and I were talking a while ago and
we realized that we both had this same
fantasy since since we were kids the one
involving Tyne Daly now
I'm going to hell so fast it's not even
funny
now we both had the same fantasy for a
long time which is what we both when we
were kids always wanted to ride an ice
cream truck just a fantasy that I think
a lot of people have had and and so we
decided that we were going to we were
going to be ice cream men in an ice
cream truck for a day and just drive
around so a couple days ago use our
power let the show open a few doors for
us exactly so we we actually got
permission to get to go to this place
where the ice cream trucks originated
and get our own ice cream truck and and
drive around in sort of the suburbs of
New York on a really hot day and it was
fun and folks this is what happened
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah we just give you a brief tour the
truck of course this is your menu
someone told me that the Hulk and
spider-man are not selling great I heard
that before so so you know it depends on
the neighborhood you know do you think
that's because as cartoon characters go
they're more complicated with a dark
side sort of both of tortured souls
might be I don't know we had some of our
own if it's okay
do we want to offer today does this one
right here it's called the French kiss
here's when we kind of want to this
one's called nutty cheeks do you think
you can sell that here's one we're
excited about the hair sickle nothing on
a hot day like a hair sickle a big
Scylla to you know the last one here and
you and I want to sell this today if
with your permission it's called the
Roker bar right it's a pretty big ice
cream isn't it yeah it is it's actually
this is not actual size the actual it's
bigger yeah it's about a 65 pound ice
cream okay just basically show us what
we need to know to dry this guy's once
you step in this is how your freezer
which you'll be using and it's it's
designed to keep your ice cream cold
over all right now
you know kids are gonna ask our
recommendation so we probably better be
familiar with the product all right so
Pete why don't you show us how to work
the truck okay well the first thing is
you want to familiarize yourself with is
the belts why women with my mind you
want to have like a little you know
pizzazz to it so I would suggest like
you can wrap it right again nice and
yeah
oh yeah I guess I completely screwed up
when I did it to say what you want to
try to make as much noise as you can so
well the kids know that hey you're here
you know they wanted my ice cream like
that that's better that's great
where's the music they also have music
on the truck alright
the volume is here on your left right
okay didn't you say restaurants which
and we also have several to this so many
let's see if I can hear it out front
how's it sound
[Music]
I'll try another town there's another
one here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
one two three four five times seventy
five cents so that's twelve dollars
please
okay let's no wait I'll go in the house
for the money you have the money now
Andy she doesn't have the money
worker 1 no grab her you're not going
anywhere you stand right here babe you
know she's priceless
we want the baby we got the baby and
when you come back you get good to come
back with the money you get the baby you
stay with me you want one of these
take a bite of this
[Applause]
what a bite it's good
[Music]
recognize us I'm Jerry Springer how are
you
I'm Jerry Springer yeah I'm John Tesh
that's John's head
you want some ice cream give him some
handy to screw in the back there you can
have these whatever they are
yeah take a whole box hey get out of
here before cops show up
hey Andy what there's an ice cream truck
right in front of us oh you should
follow him he probably knows where
there's kids put on the pursuit music
all right
yeah now he knows we're on his ass
this is a prime area right
this guy this guy led us right to candy
land what's he doing wait a minute Andy
let's get this guy's kid customers will
give it to you for free
hey kid you want to buy from him he's a
bad guy no no he's a bad guy look out
for him this way over here all the kids
over here know you don't want you know
guys you know easier just come on in and
get what you want
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
anyhow can the Good Humor company not be
happy with us now it's time to break out
the weekend
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
now we should mention this we can just
mention really quickly we really did let
all those kids come in and take the ice
cream and they became animals oh my god
and they rushed it and they grabbed all
the ice cream in there little kids were
running one with boxes and we saw those
freezer Tops come off those metal
freezer ha
we saw one little kid running down the
street carrying the freezer top right
after somebody somebody smashed Piggy's
glasses
[Laughter]
pretty we'll get letters about that
comment alright everybody I will take a
little break right now when we come back
Mira Sorvino will be with us it's a
great show stick around